the hell is the goddess of death and
I've had incredible fun playing there oh
I've missed this tell us the first
female villain that we've had in a
Marvel film and Kate has destroyed the
idea of your typical villain kneel
before your Queen loved working with
Cate Blanchett I was so excited to see
what she was gonna do
hello as this insane off-kilter attitude
you know like a smart boy how would you
like a job
I think the best villains are always
those that you kind of love and hate
what they do but you sort of understand
it there's a logic to it she wants to
come back home and be accepted and she
wants what's his you're in my seat I
would love for someone else to rule but
it can't be you you're just the worst
some of the happiest times have been
fading people out I've really enjoyed us
I caught him to speak today I can just
throw axes into someone's gut
that's been good
[Music]
everybody we're at the MCU photoshoot
hey everybody happy new footage day I
guess because it's New York Comic Con
and they're posting all that Justice
League footage over at DC Marvel wants
to get in on the fun so they're like
here have all of the hella and Cate
Blanchet is the most fantastic thing
ever
she's like Marvel winning the lottery
hopefully she never goes away
I want to see her show up in all the
cosmic movies but amongst a couple of
other background seeing changes they
said something really important during
that footage you may have picked up on
it they said hella wants to come home so
we'll talk about what that means and how
they may have combined a couple
characters from the comics to create her
they've already confirmed a few of those
but this new one you know her coming
home implies some really big things so
if you didn't know I'm doing a Thor tuga
giveaway now all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video there's all kinds of New
York Comic Con stuff dropping this
weekend too but the biggest thing first
now you get a much better look at that
background scene change they're in this
big field presumably still on Asgard
somewhere next to this body of water and
they're still wearing their old costumes
so it looks like it happens right at the
beginning of the film it gets a little
confusing because most of the footage
we've seen is with them in their new
costumes after that are on Sekar like
after Thor gets his hair cut after all
the Planet Hulk elements of the film but
the key here is when and how the hammer
gets destroyed because like this Serdar
scene here happens really early in the
film so that's before this hella scene
so it sounds like he bites Serdar first
then he comes back to Asgard finds out
what Loki
and they sort of deal with each other
then hella breaks out and then she
destroys the hammer and kicks him off to
Sekar that seems like it happens while
he is in the Rainbow Bridge here trying
to travel somewhere maybe he's trying to
go back to earth to get the help of the
Avengers or someone else you see her
kick Loki out of the beam stream so it's
like he gets dumped somewhere else first
before he makes it back to the car and
then you see her make her way to Thor he
still has the long hair so it looks like
that's how he gets just a car - so we
can make some guesses about where he
intended to escape to but this is after
his hammer has been destroyed so she
just comes after him in full force but
before I explain hella real quick I
wanted to talk about Karl Urban because
he hasn't been in a whole lot of the
trailers but he has a pretty interesting
character he's sort of like the side
villain who gets co-opted by hella but
he said that the logic in this movie is
is you see this big fight scene where
she just lays waste to all of Asgard
soldiers and then just destroys all
these ships so he sees that while
they're in the Rainbow Bridge here and
she gives him the choice you can follow
me or you can die so he's not completely
irredeemable in the movie but the whole
thing about hella here so we talked a
lot about her comic book back story
about how Odin basically tasked her with
taking care of the Asgardian underworld
she gets to call a portion of Asgardian
Souls it makes her very powerful they
also confirmed that she has some necro
sword abilities so if you know who Gore
the god butcher is from the comics but
she is not gore the god butcher himself
that's a slightly different story
but it does get into Ragnarok ideas and
when the director says that she wants to
come home and when you see Thor on the
throne here with Odin's spear and she's
like you're in my seat it almost sounds
like they're actually family and she's
the pariah who's been banished to this
other realm for this whole time for
thousands and thousands of years so she
might wind up being a version of Angela
from the comics - there's a weird right
situation with the Angela character Neil
Gaiman owns the character and sort of
licenses it out to Marvel so I think
that Marvel has just opted to combine a
couple of those characters like Angela
gore the god butcher in the hell of the
comics to create hella of the MCU and we
should probably add the cosmic entity
death to that too so really you have
four characters come
into one because Cate Blanchet is so
fantastic so it makes a lot of sense
that they would do that don't do
something with four characters when you
can do it with one especially if you can
pull it off
so if you don't know who angela is she's
Thor's sister who was taken by the
angels of heaven it's actually spelled
like this heaven it's the tenth realm
like they say the nine realms we found
out in the comics a couple years ago
there's a secret tenth realm it at some
point
Odin had a war with them and he severed
their connection to the other nine
realms but in this scene here where you
see hella throw all of her swords into
this mural up at the top here this is a
depiction of the nine realms like you
have Asgard at the center with the
Rainbow Bridge extending to Midgard in
the other realms around it Hellas
showing Scourge her plan she's showing
him Ragnarok the destruction of all the
nine realms so let me know what you
think about all this and obviously
there's that infinity war clip at the
end with Mark Ruffalo just being funny
there's a couple of people in there you
see Captain Marvel sitting next to him
Vin Diesel being really funny Michael
Rooker next to him you see Chris Evans
sitting way down here Evangeline Lilly
it sounds like they're just doing a
bunch of really glammed-out photoshoots
to promote an infinity war later this
year and they're just getting started
with that now but they'll probably drop
that in the lead-up to the actual
infinity war movie which will probably
coincide with the release of Thor
Ragnarok so mostly be promoting that
this month but after we get through that
he'll start hyping up Black Panther and
infinity war that's really when we'll
start seeing footage drop but I just
love Mark Ruffalo so much [ __ ] I wasn't
supposed to post that it was Vin
Diesel's idea Vin Diesel made me do it
but if you didn't know there's a big
Justice League trailer that are dropped
tomorrow I'll do a video for that
there's also special Rick and Morty
Szechuan sauce that McDonald's is
selling today so if I get my hands on
that then I'll post a video later
tonight for that all say congratulations
to the latest Thor ticket giveaway
winner Carlin arrestee please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for more info war and you
can click here for new Justice League
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight